[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt's eine Wickeltorte als Eistorte,
denn ich finde, es wird einmal wieder Zeit für eine Eistorte
und die Torte ist wirklich schnell gemacht.
Sie sieht kompliziert und aufwendig aus.
Ich liebe solche Torten, die so aussehen,
weil man damit einfach mega prahlen kann
und sagen kann
"Schau, was ich für dich gebacken habe."
Es ist einfach so:
Wir backen eine Biskuit-Platte
wie bei so einer Biskuit-Rolle.
Und das Ganze dauert…
Also ich meine, wenn ihr eine Küchenmaschine habt,
könnt ihr in der Zeit sowieso wieder etwas anderes machen
und im Prinzip habt ihr eine Arbeitszeit von ungefähr…
Lasst es 30 Minuten sein.
Backzeit 9 Minuten, Kühlzeit im Gefrierfach 2 Stunden - fertig!
Das war's.
Also 9 Minuten plus die 30 Minuten.
Das ist eine Torte.
Ich hab die echt innerhalb von 1 Stunde fertig
und sie ist der Wahnsinn.
Ich backe jetzt erst einmal den Biskuit.
Den Ofen habe ich schon auf 210°C Ober-Unterhitze vorgeheizt
und werde für den Biskuit mein Standard Biskuit-Rezept nehmen.
Dieses besteht aus 4 Eiern, 1 Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt und jeweils 100 g Zucker und Mehl.
Dafür gebe ich jetzt einfach die zimmerwarmen Eier in die Rührschüssel,
gemeinsam mit Salz, Vanilleextrakt und Zucker
und die Masse wird dann für etwa 10-15 Min. schön cremig verrührt.
Ich nutze die Zwischenzeit
und werde schon einmal die Zutaten für den nächsten Step anrichten.
Falls ihr mit dem Handrührgerät arbeitet,
hört euch den Podcast von uns an oder macht Musik an
und chillt einfach 15 Min. mit dem Handrührgerät.
So kann man die Zeit auch überbrücken.
Jetzt ist die Masse richtig schön cremig aufgeschlagen.
Ich muss sagen, es ist einfach immer wieder faszinierend,
wie Biskuit aussieht.
Und dann jetzt hier einfach Mehl dazu sieben.
Sieht immer aus wie ein Wasserfall.
Und ganz vorsichtig und behutsam das Mehl jetzt unterheben.
Ich backe das Ganze in meinem Backrahmen auf dem Lochblech.
Es geht am schnellsten
und ich habe wirklich nur eine Backzeit von 9 Min.
Es immer ganz exakt bei mir, weil ich einfach weiß,
wie der Ofen funktioniert.
Bei Biskuitplatten einfach immer drauf achten,
kurz und heiß backen und dann brechen sie auch nicht beim Aufrollen.
Daher auch die hohe Temperatur von 210°C
und natürlich Ober-/Unterhitze und nicht Heißluft,
denn Heißluft würde schon den Biskuit ein bisschen austrocknen.
Das nehme ich dann nur bei anderen Gebäcken,
wie Käsekuchen zum Beispiel.
Da trocknet nichts aus.
Daher hier ganz schön glatt verstreichen und sofort backen,
nicht stehen lassen und in den 9 Min…
Josh, wir schaffen es. Wir schaffen in 9 Min. den No-Bake-Boden, okay?
Ich habe hier die Zutaten schon gerichtet.
Jetzt schnell in den heißen Ofen
und dann zeige ich euch die Zutaten für den No-Bake-Boden.
Für den Crunch-Boden nehme ich 120 g Butter, 50 g Amaretti Kekse,
100 g Butterkekse
- ich habe jetzt hier die Vollkornvariante -
und jeweils 30 g Crisp Pearls
- das sind die mit Karamellgeschmack -
und Haselnüsse (gehackt und geröstet).
Okay, jetzt könnt ihr zuerst die Butter schmelzen,
entweder in der Mikrowelle oder im Topf.
Ich mache es in der Mikrowelle.
Warum verschmutze ich hier einen Topf?
Natürlich nehme ich die Mikrowelle,
aber bei niedriger Stufe,
denn ansonsten explodiert euch die Butter.
JOSH: Hast du da Erfahrungswerte?
SALLY: Ja… Nein!
Natürlich habe ich keine Erfahrung in Butterexplosion
in der Mikrowelle…
[Flüstert] Vielleicht. Vielleicht doch.
300 Watt. Ich kontrolliere es aber gleich.
Warum mache ich das nicht immer so?
Ich sag euch auch warum.
Weil eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt Mandeln genommen hätte,
ich die noch geröstet hätte.
Aber ich habe ja jetzt schon geröstete Haselnüsse.
Daher brauche ich die Röstaromen nicht.
Und dann kann ich in der Zeit schon einmal die Kekse zerkleinern.
Das könnt ihr entweder so mit den Händen machen
oder mit einem Mixer oder mit dem Whacker.
Der Whacker wurde ja ursprünglich dazu erfunden,
um Hackfleisch beim Anbraten krümelig anzubraten,
dass sich der Hackfleischkloß nicht so als Kloß zusammenbildet.
Aber ich finde,
der Whacker ist einfach für mich ein Allzweckgerät für Porridge.
Also wenn ich Bananen zerdrückte oder wenn ich Kartoffelstampf mache
oder Gemüse oder eben hier Kekse.
Man hätte auch eine größere Schüssel nehmen können, aber ist okay.
Und dafür ist es echt gut.
Dann kommt jetzt hier die Butter dazu.
Das ist immer so ein Glücksspiel mit der Butter und Butterkeksen,
denn je nach Sorte braucht man mehr oder weniger Butter,
weil eben jede Kekssorte auch einen unterschiedlichen Fettgehalt hat.
Wenn ich jetzt normale Buttekekse nehme,
brauche ich oft weniger Butter.
Wenn ich Vollkorn nehme, brauche ich ein bisschen mehr,
weil sie trockener sind.
Haferkekse brauchen weniger.
Da könnt ihr also wirklich… Haltet euch ruhig an mein Rezept.
Aber wenn einmal der No-Bake-Boden einfach zu trocken ist,
gebt ihr einfach noch einen Schwung Butter dazu
und wenn er zu nass ist, einfach nur ein bisschen Kekse.
Das ist echt so… Ja, kommt auf den Keks drauf an.
Jetzt hier noch die Nüsse und die Crisp Pearls rein.
Die Crisp Pearls sind echt mega.
Die hab ich in 4 verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen.
Nein, 5! Es gibt 3 Schokosorten: Zartbitter, Weiß und Vollmilch.
Dann gibt es Ruby und dann gibt es noch Karamell.
Die sind schon toll, weil man die nicht nur für die Deko benutzen kann,
sondern wirklich auch als Geschmack.
Die haben so einen Kekskern in der Mitte
und der bringt einfach überall einen leckeren Crunch mit rein.
Ich backe die auch mal mit.
Klar löst sich da die Schokolade und schmilzt ein bisschen,
aber so vom Geschmack her…
Die machen echt Muffins und Kuchen schon sehr, sehr lecker.
So, alles ist gut verrührt.
It's 2 minutes to go.
No-Bake-Böden - I love it!
Hier habe ich einen Tortenretter,
eine Backfolie und einen Tortenring.
Der ist bereits auf 24 cm eingestellt
und da kommt die Masse jetzt rein.
Wenn ich jetzt keine fruchtige Torte zubereiten würde,
dann würde ich jetzt hier vielleicht sogar noch
in den Boden Frucht mit reinbringen,
d.h., gefriergetrocknete Früchte, Cranberries…
Schmeckt auch immer ganz gut, also könnt ihr euch auch machen.
Aber ich bringe den fruchtigen Part oben in die Torte mit rein.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier alles schön glatt drücken
und den No-Bake-Boden in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Ja, 1 Minute, dann ist der Biskuit fertig!
Da zeige ich euch direkt, wie man ihn zum schnellen Abkühlen bekommt.
[Sally und Josh lachen]
Nein, nicht das Gefrierfach.
JOSH: Nein?
SALLY: Nein!
Ihr lacht mich immer aus - wegen meines Biskuits
und wegen meines Gefrierfachs.
Da sitzt der fertige Biskuit und hier ist wichtig,
dass man den wirklich direkt von der Folie und vom Backblech löst.
Ansonsten wird er nämlich trocknen.
Dann nehme ich mir ein sauberes Geschirrtuch
und manchmal arbeite ich mit, manchmal ohne Zucker.
Also eigentlich gehts auch ohne,
aber hier finde ich es, glaube ich, ganz hübsch,
wenn ich ein bisschen Zuckerkristalle drumherum habe.
Die bewirken im Prinzip, dass der Biskuit nicht am Tuch klebt.
Aber wie gesagt, meistens klebt er gar nicht.
Also das habe ich tatsächlich, glaube ich, sogar noch nie erlebt.
Aber kann einmal passieren,
wenn er einfach noch an der Oberfläche zu feucht ist.
Daher gerne zuckern.
Jetzt hier vom Backrahmen lösen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kurz mutig sein und einfach die Platte da drauf stürzen,
Folie abziehen
- Tada!
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach ein kaltes Blech,
mein Schnell-Kühl-Tipp.
Das dreht ihr um und dann könnte das nämlich so hochsetzen,
damit es von unten nicht schwitzt
und nehmt euch dann auch einen anderen Gegenstand.
Zack!
Und so lasse ich es jetzt einmal ganz kurz etwa 2-3 Min. abkühlen.
Sobald die erste Hitze raus ist…
Nein, ich muss ja gar nicht… Ich mache keine Biskuit-Rolle.
Ich mache eine Torte. Ich decke jetzt hier noch ein Tuch drüber ab
und dann ist die Platte innerhalb von 10-15 Min. komplett abgekühlt.
In der Zeit kann ich hier die Küche aufräumen,
kann die Creme richten, schon einmal die Füllung vorbereiten
und dann geht es einfach sofort nahtlos weiter.
Zum Füllen habe ich hier eine Marmelade.
Ich habe hier Erdbeere und Heidelbeere gemischt,
weil die Heidelbeere einfach eine supertolle Farbe mit reinbringt;
150 g insgesamt.
Ihr könnt aber auch Marmelade eurer Wahl nehmen.
Ich habe hier noch Tonka Wonka.
Das mische ich mit rein.
Für die Creme nehme ich 500 g Quark, 80 g Puderzucker,
1 TL Vanilleextrakt, 400 g Sahne und San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
Also Marmelade mit Tonka Wonka.
Und dann kann es hier direkt mit der Creme weitergehen.
Dafür nehme ich Quark.
Ihr könnt auch Mascarpone nehmen.
Magerquark habe ich jetzt.
Ihr könnt aber auch einen Sahnequark benutzen.
Je mehr Fettgehalt, umso cremiger natürlich.
Aber es kommt ja auch Sahne mit rein.
Von daher finde ich das so schon ganz passend.
Quark hab ich immer gerne, weil es so eine leichte, schöne Säure hat.
Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt.
Jetzt kurz verrühren, dann die Sahne langsam dazu gießen
und dann das Ganze mit San-apart steif schlagen.
Pro 100 g Masse, also pro 100 g Sahne und Quark einfach 1 TL.
Ich nehme da immer meine Messlöffel,
damit es ganz exakt bemessen werden kann.
Immer schön flach und dazu geben.
Am Ende immer nicht aus den Augen verlieren,
sonst kann es echt schnell passieren, dass Butter daraus wird.
Deswegen kontrolliere ich es immer lieber kurz.
Fertig!
Jetzt geht es schon ans Füllen der Torte.
Einmal kurz vom Blech ziehen.
Jetzt wird der Biskuit in Streifen geschnitten.
Ich messe jetzt erst einmal aus.
Der müsste aber eigentlich für immer so ungefähr 36 haben.
20, 30.
Ich werde die Torte nicht allzu hoch zubereiten
und schneide deswegen 5 cm breite Streifen
und die sollten jetzt ganz genau sein.
Also wirklich genau,
damit die Torte später richtig, richtig schön wird.
Dann einmal sauber durchschneiden.
Jetzt bestreiche ich den erst einmal mit der Marmelade.
Darüber verteile ich meine Creme.
[Musik]
Jetzt wieder eine saubere Palette oder die andere kurz säubern.
Hier an den Rand könnt ihr dann immer schön die Teigkarte setzen.
Damit komme ich nicht über diesen Rand hinaus
und alles wird wunderschön glatt.
So, dann kann ich jetzt hier den Ring erst einmal abnehmen
und gerne auch schon die Backfolie.
Wenn ich jetzt die Menge gut kalkuliert habe,
dann kommt es hoffentlich genau hin.
Ich nehme jetzt den obersten Part
und da außen ist es ja auch nicht ganz glatt.
D.h., da achte ich jetzt nur drauf,
dass ich praktisch diese Außenkante,
die eben nicht geschnitten ist, nach unten setze,
damit ich oben einen schönen glatten Abschluss habe.
Hier werde ich jetzt den ersten Part einfach einmal aufrollen,
zu einer kleinen Mini Biskuit-Rolle.
In die Mitte setzen.
Ich werde jetzt doch die Biskuit-Platte ganz kurz kühlen
und zwar, damit die einzelnen Streifen,
denn ich würde es schon gerne Naked lassen,
damit die einzelnen Streifen hier schön diese drei Schichten haben.
Kurz einmal entlang streichen und dann kann ich es drumherum wechseln.
Den ersten muss ich gleich ein bisschen sauber machen.
Dann wird es gut.
Ich denke jetzt… Wow, jetzt geht es besser.
Es klappt gut.
Es wird schön.
Sallys Schön-Mach-Tipps für Torten.
Ja, es ist generell so:
Wenn die Creme einfach noch so zu weich ist
und ihr so etwas machen wollt, lieber kurz kühl stellen.
Ich hatte die Platte jetzt für 10 Min. im Gefrierfach.
Ihr könnt aber auch den Kühlschrank nehmen
und da einfach solange, bis die Creme so ein bisschen fest ist.
Wow!
Ich bin richtig glücklich.
This is beautiful but… mein Boden ist so groß, minimal.
Aber das macht nichts. Ich schneide den außen herum weg.
Ich dachte vorher noch, ich mache 22 cm und dann war ich so…
Nein, mach 24 cm!
Und jetzt sind es doch 22 cm.
Schneiden wir einmal drumherum weg.
Dann hab ich noch ein bisschen Crumble für obendrauf.
Was ich nämlich bisher tatsächlich noch nie gemacht habe,
ist eine Wickeltorte, die oben offen bleibt.
Ich hab sie immer abgedeckt.
Ich finde aber eigentlich diese Spirale richtig schön
und deswegen wollte ich die einfach einmal offen lassen.
Ich lege jetzt hier eine Tortenrandfolie drumherum, einfach nur,
damit der Biskuit nicht an meinem Tortenring hängt,
denn die Torte sollte jetzt schon noch ein bisschen stabilisiert werden.
Ah, die eine hätte gereicht.
Ich benutze sie ja immer wieder.
Deswegen habe ich da immer ein paar abgeschnittene Teile im Schrank.
Den Ring einfach nur, damit die Torte jetzt eine schöne runde Form bekommt
und so kann man sie einfach nur so ein bisschen zusammendrücken.
Ganz vorsichtig.
Wonderful!
Und so kommt sie ins Gefrierfach
und kann dann gleich nur noch ausdekoriert werden.
Ihr könnt jetzt entweder eine komplett gefrorene Torte zubereiten
oder eine angefrorene Torte.
Ich bin bei Torten eher Fan von angefroren, also so 1-2 Stunden,
aber ihr könnt sie auch durchfrieren
und auch nach Belieben beim Auftauen so ein bisschen wieder antauen lassen.
Von daher wäre die Torte jetzt fertig.
Ich kann die Küche säubern und werde sie später ausdekorieren.
Schön, wir haben dieses Jahr richtig viele Johannisbeeren.
Das ist schön.
Wir haben nämlich vergessen, Früchte zu kaufen bzw. ich hab mir gedacht,
wir nehmen einfach ein paar aus dem Garten.
So können wir die Torte schön fertig dekorieren.
Oh und Blümchen.
Okay, jetzt wird die Torte fertig dekoriert.
Ich würde sagen, das ist die Vorderseite und ich hab mir gedacht,
wir machen nur so einen kleinen Bogen.
Ich hab auch noch ein bisschen Creme übrig gelassen und diese Crumble,
die ich noch vor Sarah retten konnte,
denn Sarah liebt No-Bake-Boden - die hat es fast aufgegessen.
Und dann hab ich gesagt:
"Stopp! Das brauche ich noch."
Guck, jetzt können wir hier die Früchte einfach so hinlegen.
Magst du mir mithelfen?
Wir haben jetzt hier Himbeeren, Heidelbeeren und Johannisbeeren.
Und ich mache zwischenrein noch ein paar Tupfer.
Ich gebe hier noch ein paar Crumbles drauf.
Und? Schön, oder? [Samira stimmt zu]
Gut!
Und wer dann noch will,
kann noch gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren drüber bröseln,
aber wirklich nur hier und ganz wenig.
Ich glaube, da reichen echt zwei.
Fertig ist unsere Eistorte.
Gefällt sie dir?
SAMIRA: Ja! Dir?
SALLY: Auch.
Jetzt lassen wir Sarah ein Foto machen und dann wird probiert.
Kommt, Girls! Wir probieren.
SARAH: Hä? Warum fehlt da ein Stück?
SALLY: Würd ich gerne sagen, aber Sarah hat schon die Spitze probiert.
Aber es ist eine coole Torte, oder?
JUTTA: Sarah, du hast schon genascht!
SARAH: Ein bisschen, nur fürs Foto.
Fürs Foto muss ich mit der Gabel…
SALLY: Sarah hat so einen schwierigen Job. [Sarah stimmt zu]
Ich will nicht mit dir tauschen.
SARAH: Nein!
SALLY: Aber komm, man sieht der Torte nicht an,
das es eine schnelle Torte, oder?
SARAH: Nein, die sieht…
SALLY: Raffiniert…
SARAH: Genau das.
JOSH: Wie schnell ist sie?
SALLY: Ich habe doch vorhin durchgerechnet.
30 Min. Zubereitungszeit, 9 Min. Backzeit
und dann 1 Stunde Kühlzeit. Die Zubereitung ist schon schnell.
SARAH: Also für mich ist das aufwändig.
SALLY: Aufwändig?
SARAH: Also für mich.
SALLY: Wie schnell willst du noch eine Torte machen?
JOSH: 5 Min.!
SARAH: Zusammenmischen. Ja, Torte…
SALLY: Also ein Löffeldessert.
SARAH: Ja, bei mir wird es eher ein Löffeldessert.
SALLY: Aber für eine Torte ist das schon schnell.
SARAH: Sieht gut aus. Auf jeden Fall.
JUTTA: Mach etwas her.
SALLY: Du musst erst einmal den Boden zubereiten und…
SARAH: Danke!
Ich lass euch den Vorrang.
[Lacht] Sag bloß!
SALLY: Warst du wieder Fan von.
Ah, einmal zerstört.
SARAH: Du weißt, was ich liebe.
Den Crunch-Boden.
SALLY: Und ich liebe.
SARAH: Jutta hat mir den Crunch-Boden übrig gelassen.
SALLY: Samira.
JUTTA: Aber nur aus Versehen!
SALLY: Samira, probier die Torte!
Oh mein Gott. Früchte und Tonka…
Früchte und Tonkabohne ist die beste Mischung aller, aller Zeiten!
Ich denke immer noch, da steht jemand,
aber das ist immer der Luftballon.
Oh, aber echt!
JUTTA: Und?
SARAH: Sehr lecker, richtig lecker.
SAMIRA: Der Boden macht es voll perfekt.
JUTTA: Du hast meinen Boden genascht!
SALLY: Der Boden macht's!
SARAH: Jutta, ich sage es dir: der Boden macht's perfekt.
Glaubt mir einfach. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Eigentlich ist es ja eine Biskuit-Rolle anders verpackt.
Einfach eine Biskuit-Rolle anders
und es sieht einfach so schön aus.
Und welch Zufall!
Wie der Zufall es auch so will,
bin ich heute auf einer Einweihungsparty.
SARAH: Oh!
SALLY: Beim Josh.
Ich glaube, ich nehme Kuchen mit.
JUTTA: Gute Idee. Dann kriege ich vielleicht ein Stück…
SALLY: Schneiden vielleicht der Oma noch ein Stück weg
und dann nehmen wir den Rest für den Josh.
Ich wollte es nicht verraten, wo ich heute Abend bin.
Ja, okay…
Also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken.
Das mit der Einweihungsparty war erfunden.
SARAH: Ja, das war nur ein Witz.
SALLY: Das Rezept gibt es wie immer in meiner App.
SARAH: Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
Ich habe noch etwas auf dem Herd.
SALLY: Ah ja.
Komm, wir gehen in dein Zimmer!
Komm!